philipp schnellen jetzt die
infektionszahlen rasant hoch in dänemark
sind die intensivstation alle voll ganz
klar auch in anderen ländern die
gelockert haben ist das nicht der fall
großbritannien beispielsweise die haben
gelockert bei einer inzidenz von über
400 da haben sie einfach alle maßnahmen
abgeschafft und jetzt so etwas zwei
wochen in folge fallen die
infektionszahlen also das zeigt es gibt
keinen direkten zusammenhang zwischen
jeder regierungsmaßnahmen und den
infektionszahlen das ist einfach dass es
märchen das hat sich die regierung
ausgedacht aber es stimmt so nicht wenn
man schweden und deutschland vergleich
zum beispiel bei den todeszahlen seit
zwölf monaten laufen wir da fast
parallelen deutschland im dauer lockten
zum teil und schweden komplett ohne
lockdown also gibt die maßnahmen sind
nicht das allheilmittel als dass es uns
immer versprochen wurden
letztes beispiel ganz schnell nur wild
in australien sagst du gescheitert warum
richtig australien ist wirklich eines
der spannendsten beispiele australien
war immer das erfolgs vorbild für die
ganzen deutschen noko wird berater der
bundesregierung die virologin melanie
brinkmann den epidemiologen michael
meyer hermann also die engsten berater
von bundeskanzlerin merkel die haben
gesagt wir müssen uns genau so machen
wie australien die inzidenz mit einem
locker und so niedrig wie möglich halten
also erst mal drücken und dann halten
und jegliche kritik die gesagt hat naja
dann müssen wir dem dauer locker und
bleiben werden wir versuchen die
inzidenz zu drücken
die wurde beiseite gewischt schießen ein
australien hat es ja auch so gemacht und
jetzt sieht man australien ist halt
jetzt genau in diesem dauer locker und
bei einer inzidenz von fünf oder sechs
in sydney patrouillierten hunderte
soldaten durch die straßen und sagen den
menschen dass sie zu hause bleiben
sollen
obwohl menschen kaum krank werden und
auch nicht sterben also was in
australien gerade passiert ist offiziell
das scheitern von loco wird noko wird
ist gescheitert in australien und damit
auch in deutschland das ist ein sehr
wichtiges signal wurde das muss man
vielleicht einfach noch mal so deutlich
sagen
die bundesregierung folgt bis heute in
zentralen punkten ihrer politik den
größten fans einer fulminant
gescheiterten strategie namens moko wird
die in australien einem wundervollen
freien land in nichts anderes geführt
hat als in eine pandemische form der
militärdiktatur
in dem nun auf einmal soldaten menschen
sagen wann und wo sie ein eis essen
gehen dürfen bei 800 kilometer entfernt
jemand positiv getestet worden ist das
ist die ideologie der bis heute
angela merkel zuhört und glauben schenkt
und der die gefeierten wissenschaft
stars in unserem land anhängen und damit
die politik bescheiden und nicht nur die
politik das sind auch die leute die in
den talkshows besonders im öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen auftreten
das sind die leute die uns von
überlasteten intensivstationen erzählen
die es bisher nicht gegeben hat und
diese mit der impfung auch weiter nicht
geben wird das sind die menschen die wir
uns von triage erzählen die es in diesem
land nicht gegeben hat und daran erkennt
man übrigens gefährliche ideologien wenn
ich lügen erzählen muss um menschen zu
meiner ideologie zu bringen dann ist
diese ideologie gefährlich und wir sehen
in australien was da gerade passiert es
ist anti freiheitlich es ist überflüssig
das ist ein falsches menschenbild und
ich hoffe dass sich diese sicht durch
dieses furchterregende beispiel
australien in deutschland zunimmt
durchsetzen wird wir sind bild und wie
ihr liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren